- Well, you're also, when we referred
to a minute ago at 1923
with Harrison Ford.
- [Helen Mirren] Yes. Yep.
- So like, this is incredible.
(crowd cheering)
I love all of, I love all the
there's three different
ones you can watch, right?
So I love them all, but I
I love y'all's because I just, I love
one, I love that your accent
through the whole thing,
and I love your backstory
and I love how it showed
kind of a different side
to immigrants in America
that you don't normally see
in shows like this.
Like in Wild West stuff,
like even growing up you
don't really see that a lot.
It was always just white
people, just like basic white.
Yeah.
- Well, true.
An American play. But
in, in reality, you know,
we shot in a place called Butte,
which is in Montana, which is
- I literally live an hour from it.
- No!
- I have a ranch
in Montana.
- So you know, Butte.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Well that, that's really
interesting. Beautiful.
- I live like an hour
higher up in the mountains.
- It's so beautiful, Montana.
- It's gorgeous.
- It's incredible. But Butte, you know,
has this amazing history.
Old mining town, as you know.
And, and you know, when you
look at the history of Butte
there were people from Moldavia there,
there were Welsh guys,
there were Scottish people,
there were Irish people, you know,
people from the Basque region.
So that's, that's what the West was like.
All these different
accents and cultures and
- But that's what I love
that y'all did that. Yeah.
- Yeah. So that was very much why
I wanted to play her Irish, yeah.
- Yeah. It was very, very cool.
I'm like, look, I know that
there's like, there's one store
in Butte and it's like Walmart.
So like I love
- That's true.
- that Dame Helen
- Yes.
- has been to Butte.
(laughter)
- And that Walmart.
- That's where I go
to get groceries cause where I live
is like super remote, so like that's
where I drive to get like milk.
- Yes, I know that Walmart very well.
I know it like the back of my hand.
- Me too, but I just
love that you've walked
the aisles of that Walmart.
(crowd applauds)
It's just out of like, it's
like out of pocket for me.